welcome to this video playing shushing
hi double 08 yeah tough opponent fifty
percent score i get against him got
against him eight wins eight losses two
drawers okay i think i remember that we
had some Queens gambit declines so let's
get another one should be seven as what
he mostly played yeah okay this is of
course very popular nowadays the
repulsion I'm playing this line simply
because I don't know anything which is
more critical but this is not not a bad
line to some Queen a form it's been
played by cards and end our own yarn so
yeah I keep getting this move may be
against the same guy actually possible
that we had this before okay I'm really
not sure what to do here it's putting
some pressure there on the G to pawn so
it's not so easy to develop the bishop
okay rook c1 my ideas to after a three
just taking with the jack oh I think yes
here's queen bee one check ah those
bloody Queen moves and stupid ok yes is
check quindi one queen bee to do I have
any compensation I've got to rugby three
Queen a to what looks very strange
I don't know I don't know maybe he can
do that putting the Queen down a two of
course he can check adjust and trade
queens yeah this is certainly okay for
him no he just grabs it hmm yeah that's
very very straightforward yeah I guess I
guess route be three then route then
queen to a two I played that very
quickly being obviously quite confident
that this is good man maybe it is Bishop
d3 for Bishop be one which would
actually trap the Queen he's got Knight
e5 though I'd f5 and don't have
something great against this move Knight
a fire okay let's still start with that
look before Queen III rook a for Quincy
three check that's not good maybe here
checking the pawn there on c7
is playing this very quickly maybe this
is even something known i don't know i
don't think it's it's so simple to play
but he's playing it like it's the
easiest thing in the world um yeah that
didn't go too well I can just take a
three here and when you just he can oh
ok he tries to to trap it tries to trap
it Queen be one Queen a three and then
he's all up for Queen a five hmm I seem
ok
Queen a3s double threat Queen 85 and 26
check I 494 check mmm and still Queen 85
yeah Jim well that was a disaster a real
disaster I don't really know what what
did what went wrong there okay I
overlooked queen I mean a sequel
queanbeyan one but it didn't really make
much sense to avoid it when it when it
happened let's say hi wow I can actually
take the funky fruity a check that's
totally winning can just take d 494 you
40 p a check and I'm gone I have no
moves
hmm not sure why is taking Shandling
them yeah okay white resign yeah that
was a bad bad game he had the screen g6
jennifer i already have to do have to
check that I've got it before it's a bit
a bit awkward now because I cannot so
easily move the bishop I mean maybe I
can just be should be 2m maybe I doubt
that this is really great for black yeah
maybe I have to do something like that
yeah this is simply not not a great idea
he can't do that check can really it
looks risky to put the Queen there but
yes Knight a5 yes 95 and I mean I baby s
basically saw that but it was difficult
to do something else once I was in the
end I mean you never know but he played
it very precisely knight c6 was strong
no my rook is basically trapped check
yeah and now i'm basically i'm lost
simply this is this is just told ya
totally winning so I should probably I
mean look see oneness sure actually if
we can actually questioned them yeah 95
is interesting by the way why didn't I
think about this move actually
hmm that's act is interesting I mean one
thing that is important is that in a
situation like that if black moves the
Queen I mean I don't know let's say he
goes down I am Bishop b5 this is what
the computer is giving interesting
knight c6 Bishop d7 that's an important
point the spinning thing even this I
don't really have a half 95 this is
given by stock versus equal funny yeah
95 is interesting and here already on
the this is a this is already bad for
white that wasn't a good idea maybe I
mean that's still like it should be tube
of 95 is of course very very principled
in some way yeah probably but should be
true but I think this is something that
I have to have to check really with with
the databases what is played their queen
g6 I got this before maybe against the
same guy okay well thanks for watching